the president's attacks on dr anthony
fauci
which have reached a whole new level of
incredulity
while the nation's top infectious
disease expert continues to sound the
alarm about this pandemic
in arizona yesterday mr trump said
people are quote
pandemic out he's also called dr anthony
fauci a disaster
paula reed is at the white house with
more on this story paula reed good
morning to you a lot of people are just
shaking their heads
this morning saying how is this okay
good morning gail let's start with where
the two men agree
even dr fauci says that yes americans
are tired of the pandemic
but with 13 million americans unemployed
8 million americans having fallen below
the poverty line during this pandemic
fauci says the way we get through this
is with science but yesterday president
trump
was focused on attacking fouchy and the
scientists
biden wants to lock it down he wants to
listen to
dr fauci on the campaign trail monday
president trump attacked dr
anthony fauci almost as often as he did
his opponent
he loves being on television we let him
do it sometimes he says things are a
little bit off
earlier on a call with campaign staff
the president unloaded on the nation's
top
infectious disease expert and other
scientists
people are tired of hearing fauci and
all these idiots these
these people these people that have
gotten it wrong fought she's a nice guy
he's been here for 500 years
every time he goes on television there's
always a bomb
but there's a bigger bomb if you fire
him but fouchy's a disaster
but mr trump's attacks came after fauci
spoke to 60 minutes
and criticized what he said was a super
spreader event at the white house last
month
i was worried that he was going to get
sick when i saw him
in a completely precarious situation
of crowded no separation
between people and almost nobody wearing
a mask
when i saw that on tv i said
oh my goodness nothing good can come out
of that
that's got to be a problem in an
interview on monday fauci said
the war of words distracts from the
battle against kovit what we're trying
to do
is to protect the health and the welfare
and the safety
of the american people the president
continues to hold packed rallies despite
cases rising across the country people
are pandemiced out
you know that they're pandemiced out
fauci warns that worse days could be
ahead
and that we need to follow the science
if things don't turn around and change
as we get into the cool
months of the fall and the cold months
of the winter that we may be headed into
some really more serious issues
than we've experienced former vice
president joe biden responded to the
president's attacks in a statement
he said yes americans are tired but they
are tired of your lies about the virus
they're tired of watching more americans
die and more people lose their jobs
because you refuse
to take this pandemic seriously anthony
paula thank you